♪ ♪ ♪
- On les surnomme
des bébés dragons.
Ces salamandres des grottes sont
connues depuis des siècles.
Mais on vient de leur découvrir
un nouveau fait d'armes : la
capacité de ne faire absolument
rien, pendant des années.
Complètement aveugle et albinos,
cette espèce vit dans
les grottes d'Europe.
Elle est même la vedette
d'une des plus spectaculaires
d'entre elles, située
en Slovénie.
Des chercheurs ont observé
que la plupart parcourent à
peine quelques mètres par année.
Et la plus sédentaire est restée
exactement au même endroit
pendant sept ans.
La raison est simple : c'est
que la nourriture est rare.
La salamandre détecte
les mouvements de ses proies
grâce à sa peau ultrasensible.
Et quand l'une d'elles passe
à proximité, la salamandre
peut être vive comme l'éclair!
Elle peut ensuite survivre
des années sans manger.
Cette stratégie de conservation
d'énergie extrême lui permet
de vivre jusqu'à 100 ans.
La salamandre des grottes
se reproduit en moyenne une fois
par décennie, ce qui contribue
à en faire une espèce menacée.
Des biologistes tentent donc
d'accélérer un peu les choses.
En séparant les femelles qui
viennent de pondre, on évite
que leurs oeufs soient attaqués
par une voisine affamée
ou trop territoriale.
Ces efforts semblent porter
fruit. Il y a quelques années,
on a pu assister en direct
à la toute première éclosion
de ces oeufs.
Des bébés dragons, pour qui
la vie, espérons-le, sera
un long fleuve tranquille.